rüdesheim am rhein normalerweise drängen
sich touristen dicht an dicht in den
engen gassen
doch wegen der beschränkungen durch die
korona pandemie ist in diesem frühjahr
alles anders sarah diefenbach arbeitet
hier in einer weinhandlung erst vor
kurzem hat das geschäft wieder geöffnet
nach der woche ist dann auch mal okay
und dann denkt man sich sonst nicht
jetzt auch einfach wieder raus gehen und
dinge unternehmen fällt einem natürlich
irgendwann die decke auf den kopf
damit das nicht passiert will sie mit
ihrer freundin sarah zaubern auf ein
kleines abenteuer wagen nach den vielen
wochen zu hause ein ganzes wochenende
draußen in der natur die letzten sachen
werden gepackt was genau sie bei ihrem
ersten micro abenteuer erwartet wissen
die freundinnen nicht
zu fuß geht es los
eine feste route haben die beiden nicht
bestes staat wetter allerdings auch
nicht ja also und der anderen umständen
würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach
zu hause bleiben
am meisten gedanken habe ich mir
eigentlich gemacht um wildschweine
tatsächlich aber wenn man den im dunkeln
begegnet oder wenn dieses zentrum laufen
das hört man ja sehr deutlich
na gut dass wir keine zeit haben ach
stimmt nicht mein zelt
[Musik]
ein wanderausflug allein ist noch kein
abenteuer
deswegen bekommen die teams auf ihrer
reise ganz unterschiedliche aufgaben
gestellt war von lost places gehört lost
places sind vor ort die verlassen
solche orte gibt es immer wieder mal
irgendwo in der natur und es ist ganz
spannend sich die anzuschauen
ich kann mir vorstellen dass bei euch ja
irgendwo auch so ein verlassener ort
existiert schaut doch mal ob ihr den
findet und dann durch da mal ein
bisschen unheimlich vielleicht dazu
gegen abend hier im rhein gefällt mir
spontan nichts ein
tipp gehört es gibt irgendwo hier in der
nähe so eine ruine die lehrstätte
gebrannt hat auch vor kurzem vielleicht
entdecken sarah und sarah noch eine ganz
neue welt und das in der eigenen
nachbarschaft leipzig in sachsen in den
städten ist der verlust an freiheit
durch die pandemie wohl am stärksten
spürbar
vor allem für familien mit kindern
12 341 dem einschlafen lesen haben wir
mit taschenlampen yamaha mit
taschenlampen wieder auch mitgenommen
unser notfall den assist 11 und auch im
feld zu hause die decke auf den kopf
hier hab ich mir nun teppich und sonst
kann ich nicht spielen da kann ich mich
nicht so groß bewegen zum spielen aber
in natur kann ich auch mal 100 meter in
den wald rein laufen und deshalb vom
rennen und rum räubern die familie
mokosch ko sieg hat aus der not eine
tugend gemacht und verbringt die
wochenenden seit corona vermehrt draußen
in der natur spielplätze und schulen
waren wochenlang geschlossen eine
belastungsprobe für familien
wir haben hier eine relativ kleine
wohnung wir wurden in einer schönen
stadt aber auch in einer kleinen wohnung
oder ein haus und einen großen garten
wir haben eben die natur unserer garten
sagen wir mal unsere karten den andere
haben ist ist der ganze wald um leipzig
rum herum
mit dem fahrrad geht es los
das ziel ein bootsverleih in leipzig die
familie hat sich für ein abenteuer auf
dem wasser entschieden
die mockus wie sie sich nennen haben
zwar reichlich camping erfahrung freuen
sich jetzt aber auf etwas neues
ich kann zum beispiel noch den schlaf
sei zwischen die beiden nehmen stimme
ist dass wir eigentlich relativ wenig
betragen wir haben nur mit die die
schlafsäcke isomatten ist klar eine
plane zum drunter legen und küchen zeug
zum essen kochen mehr haben wir
eigentlich mit
ich hoffe dass wir überhaupt das
hinkriegen zu paddeln und vorwärts zu
kommen mit dem ganz schwer beladen im
boot
ich habe irgendwie den eindruck wir sind
überladen
nach einer halben stunde sind alle drin
inklusive der acht taschen endlich kann
das abenteuer im vierer canadier starten
hamburg in norddeutschland im angesagten
schanzenviertel hat jimmy blum kürzlich
sein laden wieder eröffnet
hey leute halle zum top tipp des tages
ich hatte sensationellen neuen sommer
frei bekommen hat so sammer lemon und
moral sind die fahrzeuge immer mal und
denkt dann strikt sein habe ich noch aus
bella italia der hammer für instagram
bleibt heute nicht viel zeit die neue
kollektion muss zwar aus aber das müssen
zur abwechslung auf jimmy und sein mann
sven uwe ein mitarbeiter von jimmy wird
den laden am wochenende übernehmen seit
21 jahren macht das ehepaar schon
gemeinsam urlaub
doch statt nach italien geht es diesmal
ins wendland also ist das absolutes
abenteuer alleine schon outdoor zu
übernachten ich habe schon ganz früh
meine ansage zu meinem mann vor vielen
vielen jahren gemacht er liebt nämlich
so was also so wie der erste
regentropfen feld geben wir das nächste
hotel und ich habe immer gesagt ich
würde jetzt nicht an die ostsee fahren
und kämpfen weil ich weiß da kann es
auch regnen und bitter kalt sein
nun machen wir genau das und das ist
doch mal ein wirkliches challenge und
dafür das mikro abenteuer ja auch da
für das echte naturerlebnis wollen sie
die handys zu hause lassen
zur navigation muss wie früher eine
karte bemüht werden vermutet dass also
seit bestimmt zehn jahren
ich habe keine ahnung mehr mit karten
das ist immer so einfach man gibt und
was ein und dann wird das auch so
angesagt ehrlich gesagt wissen leichte
probleme gerade ohne app schaffen sie es
immerhin aufs fahrrad er ist das
tagesziel tosterglope in niedersachsen
urlaubsfeeling nach zwei von insgesamt
80 kilometern im rheingau sind sarah und
sarah mitten in ihrer ersten challenge
und suchen einen verlassenen ort eine
ruine kennt die gebrannt hat und der hat
gesagt wir müssen jetzt einmal hier dem
weg nach folgenden die suche führt sie
auf einen abgelegenen waldpfad so gar
nicht nach zivilisation also wird man
hier was finden wo ein haus besser nicht
möglich immer auf finden möchte dass sie
schon nicht gruselig aus
[Musik]
weil es dieses safe reinzugehen
ich weiß nicht manchmal kommt da
überhaupt rein
offenbar ist das haus vor ein paar
jahren niedergebrannt doch einige
persönliche gegenstände wurden
zurückgelassen
lost places sind oft baufällige
teilweise einsturzgefährdeten ruinen
deswegen ist beim betreten absolute
vorsicht geboten
ein bisschen hat ihr gestern noch jemand
gewohnt alles noch da
ein ort wie aus der zeit gefallen
das macht den oft morbiden charme von
lost places aus guck mal dafür dass ich
irgendwo dahinten am freitag noch im
feld gearbeitet habe ist das so wieso
kann ich diesen ort mit ich habe ja auch
hier unten im ort gewohnt aber trotzdem
so weit hoch in weit hoch in den wald
kam ich irgendwie nie und ich finde es
mega cool dass die ganzen sachen auch
noch hier stehen
[Musik]
lost places werden leider oft opfer von
vandalismus
wichtig ist dass man den ort genau so
verlässt wie man ihn betreten hat jimmy
und sven uwe treten seit ein paar
stunden kräftig in die pedale
das fahrrad eignet sich gut für ein
mikro abenteuer
insgesamt gibt es in deutschland
schätzungen zufolge 75.000 kilometer
radfernwege aber wo geht s eigentlich
lang ohne gps ich glaube wir müssen da
vorne rechts das richtig weiß noch haben
noch geguckt wird dieser von rechts
glaube ich kommt mit ihr beiden häuser
entschuldigung so dann hörte ich sagen
ich hab ja ich weiß es nicht ich war
doch gerade wieder zurück oder nokia
das ist doch wieder da vorne hochfahren
kurz vorm ziel erstmal immer verfahren
ja hier rechts kommt für das mal rechts
also ich kann für die mockus aus leipzig
verlaufen die ersten stunden micro
abenteuer idyllisch
[Musik]
sind immer noch in der stadt rehna auch
wenn das ja alles irgendwie in einem
kleinen urwald das bewachsen ist
das ist eben das was ich so liebe
[Musik]
abenteuer bedeutet raus aus der
komfortzone
und so steht auch hier die erste
challenge an
[Musik]
ich hoffe es läuft bei euch und ihr
kommt gut durch wir müssen mal schauen
wie ihr den nacht verbringt guck doch
mal ob ihr die chance habt vielleicht
sogar unter freiem himmel zu schlafen
aber das machen ist man so doch
irgendwie in einem geschützten raum und
so direkt neben dem wildschwein was
einem an den zehen knabbert wird es dann
schon wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
aufregender
jetzt gilt es einen geeigneten
lagerplatz für die nacht zu finden
hier könnte ich versuchen auszusteigen
nur gucken marburger schlecht schlafen
können
selbst jeder sind wir auch vom baum
dessen geschätzt das ist relativ spät
kinder damit messen können würde ich
jetzt aufgabenverteilung machen wir
haben beste was machen willst komm ich
mache es mir egal ich mache beides gerne
machen wir nach lage und wir zwei kommen
nichts was die system nicht dabei hat
damit wir die tiere im wald nicht
erschrecken haben wir alle sind die rote
lampe können die rote lampe an machen
da kann man der altar schritt nehme die
tiere nicht auch im landkreis lüneburg
wird es langsam dunkel
zur belohnung nach 80 kilometer
strampeln eine challenge ts in sichert
war das nach aufgabe auf euch die ist
verdammt schwer und zwar feuer machen
ohne feuerzeug oder irgendwelche anderen
künstlichen hilfsmitteln und guckt
einfach mal seid ihr kommt vielleicht
wird es nicht so dann gleich am anfang
aber wäre doch schön wenn es zumindest
ein bisschen
[Musik]
wir brauchen ast und ein gegenstück
möglichst trocken will ich erst mal
sagen ich war noch ganz viele häuser
hätte so und haben haben wir ein spiel
senkel von arafat an die andere
[Musik]
ja so aber jetzt zu wenig verstanden
wieso sich das wieso ist das dann drehen
[Musik]
also dieser der stock unten ist dann
irgendwann so heißt das es dann also wie
gesagt 2000 jahre haben die dafür
gebraucht bis sie zum fall gekommen sind
wir sind 2000 jahre davon wieder in
verharrt noch schuld von heute morgen
kein feuer kein warmes essen dafür die
erste nacht im zelt abenteuer in der
natur definieren die beiden eher
niedrigschwellig
am späten abend sind sarah und sarah
immer noch im wald unterwegs ohne zelt
im regen brauchen sie dringend einen
unterschlupf für die nacht
[Musik]
oder halt so denken als erstes welcher
campingkocher angeworfen hängematten
sind für micro abenteuer eine gute idee
wenn man weiß wie man sie auffängt
[Musik]
so
244 seiten
deutlich dass ambitioniert haben
geheiratet
die alternative wäre auf der bank zu
schlafen was vielleicht auch ein
bisschen ungünstig ist weil ich ja meine
isomatte zu hause gelassen habe weil die
echt groß ist ja jetzt weil sie
vielleicht doch ganz nützlich wie ist
denn der haken das ist doch trotzdem
fest uns also der nagel in die wand
[Musik]
nach dem stress endlich die kulinarische
belohnung
[Musik]
so auch alkohol
diese schon kalt jetzt abendessen auch
in leipzig
[Musik]
euro
hochprofessionell wird hier die erste
nacht im freien eingeläutet nicht
reinpassen
da drüben trends noch an unserer kannst
du mal dass mit meinem fuß weg alles gut
kinder essen einfach lassen und auf
wundervolle bereit mit dicken vollem
bauch schläft sich am besten
ich war ein paar vereinigen lieber ein
ende mit schrecken als ein schrecken
ohne ende
[Musik]
klamt
findet das kopfteil ich und du ich bin
drin
es ist super unbequem ich weiß nicht ob
es gemütliche aussieht als es sich
anfühlt aber wir schauen wir was die
nacht so bringt
der nächste morgen so richtig erholsam
war die nacht für sarah und sarah nicht
ich hab gesehen die sache nicht so gut
liegt auf der bank ganz allein war sarah
in ihrem schlafsack offenbar nicht dass
schnecke mit dem blatt ich bin
aufgewacht und neben mir hat man nicht
ganz augen aufgemacht aber ich war bei
schritte neben ja habe ich die ganze
zeit gehört und dachte ich erst dass ein
wildschwein aber es war etwas anderes
ich sag mal kurz darauf unter freiem
himmel hat die familie das erste mal
geschlafen was wirklich unbeschreiblich
schön war war aufzuwachen früh am morgen
und das erste was sie durch das kleine
loch in seinem schlafsack seas das sind
so die grasheimer mit den tautropfen
dran
das hat man natürlich im zelt mich die
sehnsucht nach natur und authentischen
erlebnissen ist groß micro abenteuer
stemmen sich all den ausreden entgegen
die wir uns immer wieder zurecht legen
man braucht weder viel geld noch
urlaubstage nur die lust neues zu
entdecken
ich glaube dass zwei solchen abenteuern
man merkt die familie als team
funktioniert und das ist ja wichtig und
ich glaube das bindet auch dass das
schweißt zusammen
anna arbeitet als lehrerin zwischen
familie und beruf bleiben ihre eigenen
bedürfnisse oft auf der strecke
die kinder sie müssen irgendwo
hingefahren werden dann muss abends
wieder essen da stehen später am abend
muss ich dann wieder die arbeit für
morgen vorbereiten
also da ist fasst nun zeit dass ich mal
sagen jetzt bin ich mal tragen jetzt
setze ich mich mal hin und bin für mich
und hier komme ich dazu weil die kinder
einfach in der natur so viele dinge
finden wo sie mich nicht brauchen für
die mockus geht es nach 72 stunden
zurück in ihre stadt wohnung
die räumliche distanz von zu hause mag
bei einem mikro abenteuer klein sein
aber im kopf ist der abstand vom
alltagsstress groß im regen machen sarah
und sarah sich auf den weg nach hause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
langsam wieder licht
[Musik]
das stück sind die straße hoch und dann
auch jimmy uns wenn uwe haben die 80
kilometer zurück nach hause geschafft da
darf man schon mal stolz sein
[Applaus]
hammer oder regal zu hause endlich haben
sie auch ihre handys wieder die wohl
größte herausforderung der letzten 72
stunden 62 nachrichten bei facebook 97 e
mails bgb und wir haben jetzt eigentlich
ein super erlebnis gehabt also ich meine
diese in seiner macht steht da die in
genau fließt seit ein paar tausend
jahren und tosterglope steht auch schon
ein bisschen länger und trotzdem war das
jetzt etwas völlig neues man muss nicht
weit fahren man kann wirklich direkt vor
der haustüre möglichkeiten finden in der
natur zu sein
ob das mit fahrrad ist ob das wandern
ist zu fuß ob das mit im boot ist das
sind eigentlich dinge die sich ohne
großartigen organisatorischen aufwand
realisieren lassen also mir das super
geholfen einfach an nichts anderes
gedacht außer wir sind jetzt hier und
das ist der moment also ich hab nicht an
gestern gedacht ich habe nicht an morgen
gebracht und dass man dann auch einfach
mal sagen kann okay wir haben hier tolle
flecken und lasst euch einfach mal
packen und wegfahren
jeder sollte das tun ein mikro abenteuer
sollte jeder sofort losgehen und machen
losgehen und machen
dann ist der schwierigste teil
eigentlich schon geschafft
[Musik]